welcome to the future of Life Institute
podcast my name is Gus Docker and I'm
here with Carl robish Show Carl is a
program officer at Long View
philanthropy where he specializes in
nuclear policy welcome Carl thank you
glad to be here great so I think you're
the perfect person to ask
about whether there is a new nuclear
conflict on the way is there a new
nuclear arms raise in the world all nine
countries that have nuclear weapons are
modernizing and improving their nuclear
Arsenal in one way or another and many
of them are doing it in response to
developments by other countries so I
think that there's already something of
a qualitative arms race underway and we
could talk more about what we mean by
that but I think we're also on the verge
of seeing a lot more nuclear weapons in
the world and that reverses a trend that
we've seen for the past 30 years or so
in which we've had progressively fewer
deployed nuclear weapons and a
perception that nuclear weapons are
something of the past and don't pertain
much to current conflicts the war in
Ukraine and some of the developments in
China and events in North Korea
Etc are forcing us to recognize that
these weapons are with us they're here
in the background even if they're
invisible and we are entering a new
phase of nuclear competition
which may not look like the past 80
years of the nuclear age so if if this
started by countries responding to each
other how did it get started in the
first place which country began this
this race so to speak part of it is a
product of technological
changes and specifically the revolution
in
accuracy and some of the changes in US
policy to pursue more effective missile
defenses and those things were driven by
an attempt to obtain advantages in
conventional Warfare and in the case of
missile defenses to deter countries like
North Korea and protect the United
States but they have this followon
effect of driving Perceptions in Russia
and China and the biggest change right
now in my view is China's decision that
they are no longer going to rely on a
small recessed nuclear deterrent but are
going to essentially seek parity with
the United States and Russia and based
on the estimates that I've seen they are
moving up to an arsenal of between a,
and 1500 nuclear weapons on a
diversified set of platforms upgrading
their command and control and moving
away from a position that nuclear
weapons were only a weapon of Last
Resort so those are some really
significant changes in the nuclear order
and I think China is responding in many
ways to things they're seeing in the
United States we also see Russia their
invasion of Ukraine relies on nuclear
weapons in the background as a back stop
to their conventional power and then the
US is responding to China and Russia
correct yes but the US is also
responding to developments in North
Korea for example so the US defenses I
don't think are primarily driven by
concerns over Russia and China but
that's not the way Russia and China
perceive that how is the US responding
to North Korea or why is that an
interesting conflict from a from a
national security standpoint so the US
has an ally in South Korea that feels
very threatened by North Korea North
Korea is in violation of multiple
International agreements and seeking
nuclear weapons and obtaining them
testing them and making nuclear threats
and this is one of those challenges that
that puts us policy makers on the back
foot all of a sudden you have a small
relatively poor and weak country that
can threaten the US Homeland with
Annihilation and that's not a position
that any US policy maker wants to be in
so there is a lot of domestic political
pressure bureaucratic pressure Etc to
try to reduce that vulnerability which
has driven an interest in missile
defenses which have become increasingly
sophisticated and an attempt to escape
from from vulnerability from North Korea
what about Taiwan is that a similar
conflict no Taiwan is quite different
here you have a long-standing US One
China policy which is based on ambiguity
but it's becoming increasingly clear
that the US would come to taiwan's
defense in an armed conflict at least
under certain
circumstances and that is fueling this
competition in the Western Pacific where
China is seeking to assume what it feels
as its rightful role in that region and
feels really constrained by the United
States by Taiwan by South Korea and by
Japan so you have this you're really on
a collision course is there a reason
these Regional conflicts are popping up
now is there some underlying explanation
that that unifies all of these conflicts
well they have been with us for a long
time so all of these conflicts have been
simmering the Korean war was never
really ended it just kind of froze in
place for from the perspective of North
Korea you have after the Cold War you
have the fall of the Soviet Union and a
decline in Russian power and US power
sort of expands NATO power expands to
fill some of that vacuum in a way that
feels very threatening to Russia so a
lot of the recent tensions are about
Russia feeling like it is on its back
foot and that its very vital and core
interests are at risk and it has lashed
out in order to preserve those interests
you China for a long time has been
rising as a major player on the
international scene and their economy
now parallels that of the United States
and wants to assume its rightful place
in the world order it doesn't want to be
a second class power anymore so it's
pushing up against some of these
historical constraints on its freedom of
of action and doing so in a way that
many people see as in violation of the
rules-based international order and we
now see the war in Ukraine you have
Russia which has invaded a country which
is getting support from NATO and is
something of a proxy war now and that
changes the dynamic pretty significantly
and the risk of this EX ating into an
allout War are very low in my view but
that risk is there and especially since
these decisions are being made by only a
handful of individuals in in the case of
Russia you have a leader who has a very
small Cadre of
advisers and it's not clear how much
information Putin is getting uh that
contradicts his
worldview and we know he's made
miscalculations before he sees the world
through a pretty narrow lens of power
and I think there's a risk that he
overplays his hand in a way that leads
to some really bad outcomes so that's
that's one issue I'm especially
concerned about at the moment I think
with North Korea you have a essentially
a totalitarian leader who's calling the
shots who also has shown some erratic
behavior and all it takes is one mistake
to dramatically change that landscape
yeah this is actually something that
worries me quite a lot how much of the
world do you think hinges on the
behavior of these specific individuals
and and other world leaders like them
how much does it matter that it's Putin
as opposed to another world leader well
as you know there's a lot of debate in
IR theory about how much individuals
matter and in what cont contexts they
matter Nations have enduring interests
but that individuals really do matter at
the margins and in some very significant
ways when you read the history closely
for example the Cuban Missile Crisis
would have been very different if you
had a leader other than Kennedy at the
helm in the United States or Cruz Chef
in the Soviet Union I don't think you
can take leaders out of this and
especially now where you have countries
that are so driven by the personalities
of of Putin of Xi Jinping of Kim Jong-un
these are countries where those
individuals particular psychological
makeup has a lot of impact on how those
countries pursue their national
interests yeah what was Kennedy's impact
in the Cuban Missile Crisis Kennedy was
so burned by the Bay of Pigs in which he
essentially trusted the military and the
CIA analysis of that situation and went
ahead with a plan that was on the books
uh from the Eisenhower Administration
and it turned out terribly and he was
blamed for it and he came into the Cuban
Missile Crisis with a willingness to
really question all of the advice that
he was getting from his military
advisers and from intelligence officials
because going into the crisis when those
missiles were detected
there was pretty much a consensus that
this was an opportunity for the United
States to invade Cuba and solve that
problem for once and for all and we know
now that if the US had carried out on
that plan that was the consensus of The
Joint Chiefs of Staff and many of his
advisers in the foreign policy
establishment it would have been
disastrous because there were already
operational tactical missiles on the
ground in the hands of the local Soviet
commanders us didn't know this at the
time but those weapons would have been
used against an invading force and it
would have triggered a massive nuclear
exchange we don't know how bad it would
have been if they would have been able
to hold anyway it would have been a
really bad situation Kennedy was willing
to question the necessity of an invasion
and push back on that advice one of the
things you hear again and again in the
in the transcripts of these these
recordings of the
deliberations he was always asking why
did kusf do this why did the Soviets do
this and that sense of empathy and
trying to figure out what are the causes
behind this was really important in
resolving that crisis uh were we lucky
that nuclear weapons were not used there
were about three or four different
places where things could have gone
wrong and I think both Kennedy and Cruz
CHF realized at that moment that while
they were sitting in the chair as the
decision maker they did not have control
of all the decisions that were being
made there were decisions that were
being made by relatively low-level
military officials uh or by parties that
didn't control like uh the leadership in
Cuba that could have easily spiral out
of control I think it was a sobering
experience to realize that in the fog of
crisis in the fog of War there's a lot
of things that can happen that we don't
anticipate we can all be grateful ful
that Kennedy acted as he did but I think
it's it is at some level a failure of
government policy that all of this
responsibility rested on one person did
did anything change after the Cuban
Missile Crisis in terms of of policy did
we make any rational improvements in in
how we we manage risk around this
technology in some ways yes there was a
hotline that was put in place so that
the leaders could talk directly to each
other in real time during a crisis but
that of course only applied to the
United States and the Soviet Union and I
think it was a sobering moment and led
to changes in the way that Kennedy and
kusf viewed nuclear crisis but of course
they were only part of the story and
Kennedy was soon assassinated kusf would
later leave the scene and behind them
was this military imperative so both
sides took away very different lessons
from the Cuban Missile
Crisis in the United States the lesson
that was taken away was that in order to
Prevail in a nuclear
crisis you cannot blink you need to
stare down the adversary and by showing
resolve uh and by having more weapons
and more
capabilities uh you're going to be able
to get your way that was the perception
in part because nobody knew that Kennedy
and kusf had both blinked they had both
agreed at the final minute to strike a
secret deal to remove the missiles from
Turkey in return for the missiles in
Cuba and that was the key that unlocked
the crisis and allowed for a
deescalation but that information was
only known by a handful of people and as
a result the conventional wisdom was you
know you got to stay strong in a nuclear
crisis interestingly on the Soviet side
side the takeaway from the entire Soviet
leadership was that we cannot allow
ourselves to be vulnerable in this way
we need to build up our nuclear Arsenal
because at the time of the crisis the US
had a huge qualitative and quantitative
advantage in nuclear arms and the
Soviets looked at that and said we got
we just got bullied here because we
don't have enough to to to preserve our
interests and that led to a massive
buildup throughout the 60s and put the
world in a much more dangerous place in
the United States we still rely on one
decision maker the commander-in-chief
decides when and how to use nuclear
weapons based on plans that are
formulated by stratcom and the Pentagon
But ultimately that one individual is in
charge and initially that system emerged
as a check on the power of local
military commanders to use these weapons
so the sole Authority emerged when
Truman basically said these are not
normal weapons of war I want to be the
sole decider when it comes to using
nuclear weapons again but over time that
system has perpetuated itself even as
we've strengthened our Command and
control we can make decisions faster
with better information but we retain
what I view as a really outdated mode of
decision making around nuclear weapons
and that has real implications for today
because you're going to have a president
in the White House whether it's
President Biden or president Trump who
is in their 80s or might be forced to
make the most consequential decision
ever made by someone on earth right yeah
that's pretty terrifying are there any
prospects of getting rid of this one
person decision process for for nuclear
weapons there has been some legislation
proposed in Congress that would change
this and would say that under certain
circumstances the president can use
nuclear weapons without going to
Congress but in order to use nuclear
weapons first or if there's no time
pressure the president would have to
first consult either yeah there a couple
different variants some people say there
would be a conversation with Congress
more often uh you know there would be a
couple other decision makers including
the Secretary of Defense and The Joint
Chiefs of Staff to have a an expanded
circle of decision makers around nuclear
use and this is what we have on the
books at least in Russia uh and in some
other countries where there isn't just
one individual who makes that decision
is that how it actually works in in
Russia is there a council so it's not
just just Putin himself who decides yeah
there are three individuals including
the Russian president the minister of
defense and I'm blanking now on her the
third individual is how it would play
out in
practice is that you would need someone
who's willing to speak their mind in
opposition to what Vladimir Putin
prefers so I mean in an Ideal World the
leader of Any Nation when taking a
decision this big would want to consult
a variety of different sources of
information and really reflect on that
decision we are likely to face some
nuclear decisions that come under
extreme time pressure and psychological
stress
and that's one thing that scares me
because we know that humans don't make
decisions well
under stress and extreme time pressure
and when these decisions are of such
high consequence you got to get them
right every time we talked about how
much individual world leaders matter in
in the course of of history of of
nuclear weapons and uh nuclear policy
how much do you think ideology matters
you could see the Cold War as as a clash
of ideologies around how economics
should work it seems to me that that for
example Russia's invasion of Ukraine
seems ideologically driven the North
Korean regimes seems like an
ideologically driven um Enterprise how
much how much does ideology matter for
for the way States think about nuclear
weapons both Russia and China see
themselves as pushing back against this
Western order with its embedded values
um which are economic cultural social
and on this you know we call the
rules-based international order
but which these countries see as you
know the you follow the rules when it's
in your interests and then when anyone
else Breaks the Rules you use your power
to overwhelm us and dictate the terms
right and so I think that ideology
remains a a a force and if you think
about ideology broadly to include
nationalism or in the case of North
Korea the sense that they are the this
chosen people that have a special
Destiny in world affairs um I think it's
hard to separate out pure national
interests from an
ideological interest and it's not just
about National ideology there's a lot
that comes in about uh you know
perceived Grievances and slights and a
sense that my country and I am being
disrespected and I need to do this in
order to gain back respect or else it's
going to keep happening to me over and
over again I think that that is one of
the big risk factors is that someone
does something that may not be in their
National interest or their personal
interest because they're angry because
they're upset you know decision makers
are human too we can all think about
instances in our own lives where we've
done something we've regretted In the
Heat of the Moment
and there's this illusion sometimes that
states are utility optimizing entities
rather than um subject to the the same
same whims that the people at their Helm
are but for states the the consequences
of of of acting out on on these impulses
might be considerably greater than than
in our kind of personal conflicts of
course yeah I mean it can put everyone
alive on this planet at risk to one
degree or another
a single person's decision and that's
shocking and that is something that's
new to The Human Condition you know for
a few million years there have been
humans on this planet and modern
Humanity goes back tens of thousands of
years right and during that entire time
there were individuals who had
incredible power if you think about
gangas Khan or Alexander the Great right
but nobody could push the button and
create Global consequences in the course
of an afternoon and that is a new
development that emerged you know over
the past 80 years and you know there
wasn't one line that was crossed it was
a series of lines that were crossed as
we unlock the fision bomb and then the
thermonuclear bomb and then
intercontinental ballistic missiles and
improved the number of weapons and the
accuracy of those weapons so each time
you're Crossing the the these thresholds
but we live now in a world in which in a
really short period of time a very small
number of
individuals can
create really awful outcomes somewhat
paradoxically maybe we also live in a in
a in a time of relative Peace So for for
the last 80 years say we we've managed
to avoid World War I do you think
nuclear weapons are responsible for for
holding the world in a kind of peaceful
stalemate yeah so a lot has been written
on this and I think nobody knows for
sure and we have a puzzle in which you
have this dependent variable which is a
relatively long period of Peace absent
great power conflict and then you have
lots of explanations for it people argue
for example that the ideological
divisions between the US in the Soviet
Union or the West in the Soviet Union
allowed them to step back and feel like
time was on their side and that they
didn't Mo need to move quickly other
people's look at the general exhaustion
of the European powers and of the Soviet
Union after World War II and look at the
the fact that Soviet leaders were not
willing to embark on a new wave of Wars
to promote their interest because they
were essentially exhausted and wanted to
focus on rebuilding their country and
then other people look at international
law and the spread of rules and values
personally I don't think that those
variables explain everything I think
nuclear weapons played a role in this
restraint I think there is a lot of
evidence that leaders of nuclear armed
States really grappled with the fear of
unleashing nuclear war and what those
consequences could be and I think that
led them
to exercise more caution in in starting
a war than they otherwise might have I
think there's a better question we might
ask though which which is in expectation
did the nuclear policies we pursued make
us less safe or more
safe and I feel confident that the
answer to this question is that the
nuclear buildup actually made us less
safe even if you do have this period of
Peace it came at a cost which is that
every year we were rolling the dice with
the potential for Global Annihilation we
were taking chances that could have led
to 300 million to 500 million people
dying directly from nuclear blast and
that doesn't take into account the
effects of fire of radiation the
potential for nuclear winter or nuclear
Autumn right so you have the potential
for billions of people to die as a
result of this nuclear
standoff and even if we were able to buy
some piece the cost of that piece is
this underlying risk that you're going
to lose it
all what were the odds that nuclear
weapons were used during the Cuban
Missile Crisis nobody knows for sure I
believe the odds were certainly more
than
1% and I think they were probably closer
to 30% or 50% which is what President
Kennedy put them at and remember when
Kennedy made that estimate he didn't
know about some of the things that we
know now right we only learned later
about the incident with the b-59
submarine which almost launched a
nuclear torpedo we only learned later
that there were Soviet officers with
tactical nuclear weapons that were
authorized to use those and those
weapons were fully operational so there
are lots of things that may have made
the situation even risk ge now you know
you could say also Kennedy had reason to
inflate that risk in order to make
himself seem like a hero and justify the
actions we took so we don't know what
his actual risk assessment is and that's
the problem with all of this is that
it's impossible to determine what the
underlying risk
is one of the reasons it's impossible to
determine that is that risk is dependent
on the actions that individuals take so
in some cases the higher the perceived
risk the lower the actual risk and vice
versa there's a lot of risk compensation
behavior that occurs in the nuclear
space and that's one of the reasons that
it doesn't lend itself to sort of a
simple game theoretical analysis if I'm
hearing you right the the cost of world
stability is this underlying risk but
that underlying risk is difficult to
estimate correctly because people
respond to the risk by by decreasing the
risk that's right in some cases they may
respond to the risk by increasing the
risk if they feel like the risk is very
low they feel like they can leverage
that risk in order to achieve something
that's really important to their country
and I think you see both behaviors
happen throughout the course of the
nuclear age yeah it's a dynamic system
like the economy it's it's not like a
natural phenomenon exactly right and you
see that you see that in Ukraine today
right where Vladimir Putin has made
nuclear threats in order to limit NATO's
support of Ukraine in that
war and he's manipulating risk right now
if NATO entirely discounts that nuclear
threat then maybe the nuclear risk
actually goes up on the other hand if
NATO takes that nuclear threat really
seriously and acts as if Russia's about
to use nuclear weapons
Russia may be able to achieve more goals
and feels emboldened to make more
nuclear threats so again this this
Dynamic it's very
multi-layered how do you even make
decisions in in such a system how do you
make an all things considered decision
when when you have all of these
interacting effects well I think that
the way decisions are usually made by
policy makers is they have these mental
models they apply that mental model to
the situation
that confronts them I have no evidence
that leaders are using uh probabilistic
estimates and sophisticated models of
risk assessment and cost benefit
analysis in order to achieve their goals
there are people in government who do
that you know when when designing
nuclear plans for example there's a lot
of thinking that goes into that but In
the Heat of the Moment decision makers
are politicians in most cases and they
use these simple models of how they
understand the world to navigate this
new challenge that faces them they're
not obligated in the US system for
example to to take into account models
that are provided to them they don't
have to respond to any of the
information there that's provided to
them I think that's right and I don't
think it's just in the US system I think
in basically any system there is a small
Cadre of decision makers and really
often as dominated by one
person and they will make a choice when
faced with the choices presented to them
they may pick one of the items off the
menu or they may opt for something
that's not on the menu as as Kennedy did
when he imposed this quarantine around
Cuba I think there's a view in
government at least in the US that the
US that the President should have a lot
of options to choose from whether that's
a wise thing or not you'd have to ask
someone who's really uh expert in
decision Theory uh do we operate better
when Prov provided a broad menu of
options or a narrow menu and in some
cases I think a large menu can confuse
us and in some cases having a a few
middle options which are still very
extreme may make those middle options
seem more palatable and sensible if that
makes sense yeah it's as you mentioned
before we can imagine Putin responding
only to the information that's being fed
to him and maybe the people feeding him
information have various incentives not
to be entirely straightforward and of
course Putin himself can punish people
for providing information he doesn't
like and so on it's interesting to
consider how much human psychology goes
into making these decisions whereas in a
better world I I think it it should be a
bit more considered or reliant on
systems that we have develop why we were
sure we were thinking straight yeah and
you know 10 years ago I was really
concerned about that problem as it
pertains to North Korea I think today we
increasingly need to be concerned about
that problem uh as it applies to Russia
and to China which uh you know have
increasingly personalistic leadership
and I know there are a lot of people in
the United States too who are concerned
about Donald Trump president Trump if he
wins again um will be in charge of these
decisions and has shown an inclination
towards taking extreme rhetoric if not
Extreme Action if we return to to North
Korea do do you think North Korea could
ever be invaded or otherwise affected by
the outside now that it has nuclear
weapons North Korea has long feared an
invasion from the United States and
South Korea but I don't think that that
fear was ever really warranted I think
it reflects some paranoia on the part of
North Korea what their nuclear Arsenal
has not protected them from are from
sanctions which have impoverished and
isolated their country if you go back to
the end of the Korean War North and
South Korea were roughly similar in
terms of their their economy if anything
the north was stronger and richer and
today there's no question that the South
has flourished whereas the north has not
and you could just look at these
nighttime satellite photos that are
taken and you could see just a couple
blips of light in North Korea but
otherwise it's entirely dark and South
Korea is just shining with economic
activity and prosperity so by any
objective measure North Korea's policy
of seeking nuclear weapons to advance
its interests has backfired I think that
they are losing ground you know would
the United States and South Korea have
conducted military air strikes absent
North Korea's nuclear weapon possibly
and and especially in response to some
of North Korea's most provocative
actions like the shelling of an island
that killed many South Korean service
members but I do think that South Korea
would be deterred by North Korea's
conventional capabilities you know soul
is basically within range of North
Korean conventional artillery so I don't
know how much North Korea's nuclear
weapons have bought it far from being
protected by nuclear weapons nuclear
weapons are the major reason for North
Korea's suffering but in some ways these
weapons do insulate the Kim regime from
the laws of gravity as it pertains to
you know that he has this power and this
security that he can he can brandish
against these external threats and he
can motivate people to to unify against
this external threat yeah it's it's
important to remind yourself of the
difference between North Korea as a
country and Kim's personal interests
which are not always perfectly aligned
do you think the annual risk of of
nuclear war has been overestimated in
the past so is it is the case that we've
thought that the risk was higher than it
that it actually was if you have a one%
risk each year for 80 years and continue
running that into the future at some
point it becomes just mathematically
improbable that that the world still
exists and so you might begin to doubt
your numbers what do you think of these
estim
well I think that the risk of nuclear
war has been overestimated and
underestimated depending on who's doing
the estimating because most of these
estimates come with a political agenda
right so if you want to rid the world of
nuclear weapons you are likely to
overestimate the risk that they will be
used on the other hand if you see
nuclear weapons as legitimate tools of
diplomacy and military power uh you
might underestimate the risk that
threatening to use nuclear weapons will
lead to nuclear war and I think you see
both of those Dynamics throughout the
Cold War the fact is that almost nobody
has systematically sought to estimate
the annual risk of nuclear war and I
think it's virtually impossible to do it
it's worth trying because in trying to
do that I think you can isolate some of
your assumptions and some of the points
of disagreement and some of these cruxes
between people who have very different
worldviews but there's also this other
problem Gus that we talked about earlier
which is that if you have a high
estimate of the risk you are likely to
take actions that then reduce that risk
you know a good example is the risk of
nuclear terrorism right so if you go
back to the early 1990s a lot of policy
makers and the United States were
talking about how there's the potential
for a non-state actor to acquire and to
use nuclear weapons of course that
hasn't happened in the intervening years
and our default would be to say well
they way overestimated this risk it's
really hard for non-state actors to
acquire these materials and this was all
a distraction and maybe that's true but
I also think that because we had that
risk in mind there were a lot of actions
taken by the United states by Russia by
the former Soviet states that
dramatically reduced the availability of
fistle material that reduced the
likelihood of proliferation both to
State and non-state actors that work to
disrupt the networks of non-state actors
that might be able to find a safe haven
and work on these bomb projects in
secret and so I think that those
interventions were worth taking because
nobody really knew what the underlying
risk was and the consequence
of the use of even a handful of nuclear
weapons or even one nuclear weapon in a
major city are large enough that the
money that we spent to to secure and
reduce those materials made a lot of
sense yeah there's the direct deaths and
the there might be additional deaths
from from radiation and from from smoke
and so on but there's also just the
imagine the the the political
instability caused by a nuclear weapon
used in a major city that that would
also be extremely costly for the world
if you think about the second and third
order consequences of the 911
attacks uh to the global economy and the
the the backlash that led to multiple
Wars and major instability led to
infringements on civil liberties you
know the violation of international law
and and and torture and
surveillance and you know the the fact
that we're still all these years later
taking off our shoes every time we go
through an airport security line that's
like a very you know a very small
inconvenience but compounded by millions
of people every day since it's like
these costs endure and once you put in
place something it's unlikely to be
rolled back so if a nuclear weapon is
used again on us soil I'm not confident
that our democracy surv sures that our
constitution
survives it might but it might not and
that's one of the reasons I think it's
worth investing a lot of time effort
expertise and Care into avoiding these
weapons from ever being used again let's
talk a bit about nuclear near misses
this is one of these subjects where you
you get a sense of what the risk might
be even though we don't we're not
engaged in trying to estimate an a
probability but there are stories of
near misses where you think this could
have easily gone the other way so do you
have some near examples that you like to
use yeah I mean there were three or four
during the Cuban Missile Crisis alone
which I think is the most dangerous
moment in human history is especially
risky because the you know the tensions
were so elevated I think it's unlikely
that we will end up in a nuclear war
that comes out of nowhere the Cuban
Missile Crisis built on a series of
other escalations and and also you have
a case in which the decisions were
happening very quickly and then they
were in no individual's hands I give you
one example of this I mentioned this
submarine these b59
submarines Soviets they were originally
designed for the Arctic so they were
never meant to operate in warm Waters
they get their orders to go down to the
Caribbean to support the C the
operations around Cuba
and it's not even clear what these
submarines are there to do but they are
armed with these nuclear tipped
Torpedoes uh and as they approach they
are discovered and the US Navy starts
dropping depth charges to force them to
surface now they're signaling like we
found you come up but the submarine
officers the worst thing you can do if
you're in the Soviet Navy is to surface
and give up your ship it's humiliating
and you're likely to suffer a lot of
consequences it's everything you're
trained is to avoid that so they are
being blasted you imagine being in a tin
drum with someone hammering on the
outside of that drum and it's 130
degrees Fahrenheit because you these
these ships were meant to operate in the
Arctic and now they're in the Caribbean
it's the stress that these guys under is
extraordinary and the captain of the
ship says I'm not going to go down like
this I think the war might have already
begun they've been out of touch with
Moscow and he authorizes the use of
their special weapon this nuclear
torpedo against the US Navy ships there
and there's a commissar on board as well
who has to sign off on the order he
signs off and it just so happens that
the commandant of the fleet vasel arapov
was assigned to this specific boat and
he looks at the situation a little
differently and he says you know let's
let's wait to get more information I'm
not about to start World War III without
knowing that the war is underway and he
halts the order now if he hadn't been on
that boat or if he had taken a decision
that nuclear torpedo would have been
used the first use since
1945 and could have easily spiraled out
of control
into W allout nuclear war because the
you know the US nuclear war plans at
that time with single integrated
operating plan which basically called
for the release of everything we had
against not just the Soviet Union but
their Eastern Europe allies and so and
and communist China would have
been the worst day in human history and
it may have been avoided by virtue of
this this one individual saying let's
not do this you know within that crisis
you have a number of decisions made by
both Kennedy and kusf to you know to
pull back from from
escalation and you had a lot of decision
makers strangely enough you had a lot of
people who had the opportunity to use
nuclear weapons during that crisis or to
trigger a crisis that would lead to the
use of nuclear weapons so this illusion
of control is one of the things we need
to get away from I think uh in the
intervening years we probably have
gotten better at this uh in in terms of
uh you know the training that is
provided to Military Officers as well as
enhancing
Communications command and control we
should be really cautious about assuming
that the system will work as it's
designed to work every time into the
future and it's worth thinking about why
such power was assigned to one person
whether that's Kennedy or an officer in
the first place and I I think that has
to do with with time pressure the
incentive is to have a quick response if
the enemy is firing nuclear weapons at
at you but as you mentioned before
humans just aren't good under under time
pressure in making extremely
consequential decisions have we done
anything about about the time pressure
or has this problem just become come
more intense the problem has
continued and we have developed the
means to avoid this problem but we
haven't really implemented them that is
to say that within the United States we
have a very robust early warning and
command and control infrastructure which
in principle give the president a lot of
time to wait and to decide and to see
whether a nuclear weap has actually
detonated or not before using uh before
authorizing a response in the case of
the us we have these ballistic missile
submarines Each of which has a massive
amount of Firepower on them one of those
boats is essentially enough to deter any
threat the US might face and the
president could choose to take as much
time as they wanted to before
authorizing that response in the case of
the United States
the thing that is driving time pressure
well there are really two one is this
fear that the intercontinental ballistic
missiles which are landbased
missiles are vulnerable to being taken
out so that is one of the drivers of
time pressure uh you you might only have
15 minutes to make a choice to either
use those weapons or to lose them and
secondarily this this fear that the
president and the vice president and
other leaders could be killed in a
nuclear attack and that would delay the
US response so those are the two things
that are driving the need to move very
quickly and I think we should reject
that and move away from that and move
towards uh a policy in which we're only
going to response once we're 100% sure
that we are under nuclear attack um that
would make the world a lot safer but
there are various bureaucratic and
political obstacles to making that
happen now that's the US system this is
the country that has spent the most on
its nuclear command and control and on
really highly professional training for
its Military Officers there are nine
nuclear countries nobody knows exactly
what the security of the launch
procedure are in each of those countries
or the vulnerability to interdiction to
Cyber attack to kinetic attack to The
Cutting of communications channels to
electronic warfare nobody knows how
vulnerable all of these
decision-making um chains are my hunch
is that the window for making a decision
in North Korea or Russia or China or
Pakistan is in fact quite a bit shorter
and each of these countries has um you
know different infrastructure right so
in some cases the weapons might be Dem
in which case there might be a longer
window for actually using the weapons
but the decision to use the weapons
might have to be taken very quickly
especially if there's there's there's a
fear that the national leader themselves
is at risk of being killed as bad as it
is in the United States I'm concerned
that it's even worse in some of these
other countries and that this chain that
that supports all of us it's only as
strong as the weakest link
because if a leader in North Korea is
acting upon erroneous information and
using nuclear
weapons that imperils all of us so the
US has the technical ability to detect
whether an apparent nuclear strike is is
is genuine before they launch a
Counterattack but but it's not
politically feasible to implement that
system in in the us today it hasn't been
so far right tell me if this is insane
but is there any possibility of of the
US exporting that technical system to
other countries it seems like a a
genuine good for for all nuclear states
to have this system but I don't think it
could be trusted by other states yeah
you imagine uh Russia's response if we
offered to share our our wisdom with
them on this what kind of loopholes or
Trojans would be built into that system
right unless perhaps we could somehow
prove to them and here I'm thinking
mathematically or in in programming
language that the system is is safe in a
way that they could use it it seems like
a like a fantastic opportunity to to
have the system that helps decrease
accidental nuclear launches I I couldn't
agree more of course that system to
prevent accidental launches is also the
same system that enables you to launch
nuclear weapons under a variety of
circumstances including not just in
response so China is upgrading its
nuclear command and control in part
because they're concerned that in a
crisis the US would try to preempt its
nuclear
Arsenal uh you know try to take out its
satellites and its Radars and cut its
Communications nodes and try to strike
the missiles while they're on the ground
leaving China vulnerable to us coercion
that's the fear in Beijing so that's one
of the reasons they're investing so much
in their nuclear Arsenal they don't want
to be bullied and they they want to be
able to threaten and intimidate the
United States as we discussed before
then you have this unfortunate scenario
of the US responding to to China's
actions which causes China to respond to
the US sanctions and so on how do you
get off this treadmill I think you need
a country to
say we have nuclear
sufficiency we
have enough weapons across enough
platforms to feel that we are safe and
secure regardless of what our
adversaries are doing I think right now
from a technical and a strategic
standpoint the US has that but
politically it's risky to sit there
while China is tripling the size of its
Arsenal and to say we're not going to do
anything um similarly with Russia right
so the United States have equivalent
numbers of deployed strategic nuclear
warheads Russia also has some of these
tactical nuclear warheads which aren't
counted under those agreements they're
generally very short range and have very
limited utility but people in the US are
concerned about that and and rightfully
so right but this agreement that we have
this new start
treaty limits the it it puts a ceiling
on the number of deployed Warheads you
can have but incidentally it has also
set a floor on the number of
weapons because nobody wants to go below
the the number they're permitted under
the treaty and so that's one of the um
unintended consequences of this
agreement it would be you know
politically costly to negotiate this
agreement and then say actually we only
need a thousand nuclear weapons to keep
ourselves safe which is actually what
the you know the the Pentagon did a
review joint Chief of Staff during the
Obama Administration and they determined
that all of us goals under a variety of
possible Futures could be met with a
thousand nuclear warheads right but that
number was politically unpalatable
because the US didn't want to have fewer
Warheads than than Russia all of the
Strategic objectives could be met by a
thousand nuclear weapons but they had to
had more than than their main adversary
why is that why why did the US ever and
and Russia too why did they ever have
thousands upon thousands of of nuclear
warheads what happened there yeah I mean
it's an interesting story and it really
goes back to the beginning of the
nuclear age so from
1949 which is when the Strategic Air
Command creat its first nuclear war plan
to 1955 that's a six-year period you
have a 14-fold increase in the number of
nuclear targets more and more weapons
are coming with greater and greater
yield by
1960 the US Arsenal has the equivalent
explosive capacity of
1.4 million hirosima so we're talking
about 18,000 total weapons over 3,000
strategic weapons on a variety of
different platforms the Soviet Union has
also dramatically increased its
capabilities though they don't have as
many weapons or as many deliverable
weapons as are feared in the US so this
is another example of the kind of threat
inflation that fuels this bureaucratic
process and by the 1960s the Soviets
have a similar number of weapons a
similar amount of Firepower and we are
in a place that leaves both sides much
worse off in a a situation that nobody
would have hoped for that nobody would
have chosen if they could have signaled
restraint from the start and and
believed that the other side would have
restrained themselves is the US
government or the Soviet government
acting as a monolith here you mentioned
different military departments is there
a sense in which each department is
interested in having their own stockpile
of of nuclear weapons to increase their
relative power within the their
respective militaries yeah so in the US
which is the case that I know best
there's definitely this interservice
rivalry where nuclear weapons start off
uh loaded onto bombs in the domain of
the Air Force and the Air Force starts
getting a lot of money and a lot of
attention and incre increasing its
status within the arms forces so both
the Army and the Navy want part of this
nuclear Mission I mean I think they
genuinely believe they were ing US
National Security and they wanted to
find ways to do that but there was also
an interest to remain relevant in a new
world you know that's how you have
nuclear missiles that are operated by
both the Army the Navy and the Air Force
Right Along Comes the the Navy and they
have a new design for a submarine
launched ballistic missile called the
Polaris and this creates a real crisis
for the Air Force and they how you know
this weapon is really good and it's
relatively invulnerable unlike our
bomber bases and our icbms which you be
taken out the Navy now has this missile
coming online that there's a ran study
about how the Air Force should respond
to this and the title of the study is
very telling it's called the Polaris
problem not not like the Soviet problem
but they see the Polaris as being a
fundamental challenge to to their role
in the world and so they come up with
new Concepts that involve more precise
delivery of nuclear weapons which is
something that their more accurate
missiles and that their bombers can do
um which the the Polaris at that point
is not a very accurate missile you have
this interservice rivalry within the
United States that's fueling more
targets more weapons more modes of
delivering them you have the same thing
on the Soviet side I less familiar with
that but they spent so much of their
National Treasure on trying to catch up
if the situation wasn't as serious as it
is it it would almost be funny that you
have you know military personnel acting
as as boys in a schoolyard seeing who
can have the shiniest toy it almost
sounds like like that that's why I think
the greatest nuclear film ever made is
Doctor Strange Love and it's based on
the same material that was used in the
movie failsafe but whereas failsafe
plays it straight Doctor Strange Love is
this dark comedy and it reveals the way
in which these Trends are just so
farcical right um and yet the stakes are
so high you mentioned a couple of times
that the world only has nine countries
with nuclear weapons and and I say only
because you could have imagined a world
in which say 200 countries had nuclear
weapons and and in which they had
perhaps much larger stockpiles why were
nuclear weapons contained to to only
nine countries yeah is a great question
and it's something I've given some
thought to because it's kind of
counterintuitive right so you have this
technology that emerges in the 1940s at
same time as jet engines and microwave
ovens it's hard science it's hard
engineering but it's not that hard and
we've seen that it's not that hard
because there are countries like
Pakistan and North Korea that are
relatively poor and don't have
state-of-the-art technology in other
areas that are able to master the use of
nuclear weapons right I think it's a
puzzle that has a few different answers
first you have this system of military
alliances which reduces the necessity
for many countries of pursuing these
weapons so many of the countries in
Western Europe who who had the technical
capability to pursue nuclear weapons
decide not to because they can rely
instead on protection from NATO this
nuclear Alliance and in parallel the
Soviet Union leans on its eastern block
allies and says hey you don't need to
get these weapons uh knock it off right
so that's one big factor so a second
factor is direct military action or
sanctions um that that tried to limit
countries from acquiring nuclear weapons
these can work against relatively weak
States but they're not likely to be
successful against strong States or
states that are protected by alliances a
third piece of the puzzle is this
International treaty regime that emerges
and it doesn't really come up until the
1960s and it starts off very weak but by
1968 you have this nuclear
nonproliferation treaty that essentially
is is a bargain between the countries
that have nuclear weapons to say that
they won't spread this technology and
that they'll work towards a cessation of
the arms race and that they'll share the
peaceful benefits of nuclear energy in
return for those countries that don't
have nuclear weapons to credibly and
verifiably not pursue nuclear weapons it
starts off very very weak with poor
adherence but just a few years later a
lot of countries have signed on and a
lot of countries end their nuclear
weapons program at this point so it's
not well appreciated but there were
dozens of countries that at least
pursued nuclear weapons to some extent
and some of those programs were very
serious and you start to see in the 60s
and 70s those programs start to taper
away because for most countries it's
expensive and risky to try to acquire
nuclear weapons and if you can get your
security in another way you should do
that it would be preferable but how can
can you be sure that your neighbor won't
acquire nuclear weapons and threaten you
well that's one of the great things
about this nuclear nonproliferation
treaty is it allows you to sign up and
indicate that you're not going to not
going to pursue nuclear weapons but it
also has this verification mechanism
through the international atomic energy
agency um which can come and take
measurements and make assessments to
show that a country's program is
peaceful in nature those are three key
factors but I think there's a fourth too
that is probably
underappreciated which is that along
with this this formal legal regime comes
a change in in norms and a change in
views and when the nuclear age started
nobody really knew what to make of these
weapons were these just another military
tool like any other or were these
something fundamentally
different and over the next couple
decades there's a big debate about that
but in most countries nuclear weapons
come to be seen as something different
and a particularly horrible weapon that
has disproportionate effects on on
civilians and on Innocents and which is
hard to contain and so countries feel
there's a normative element to signing
onto the nuclear nonproliferation treaty
and holding to that agreement they want
to be the good guys they don't want to
be pursuing these weapons which are
truly horrible and so there's a story
they start to tell themselves and that
story I think explains some of the
stickiness and the success of this
nuclear nonproliferation treaty at least
for democracies when countries sign on
to this treaty they generally adhere to
it and there's very been very little
cheating on this treaty by democracies
because they have rule of law they have
domestic law there and and and it
becomes embedded in their identity um
and you see that today with this this
effort in the treaty on the prohibition
of nuclear weapons weapons to ban
nuclear weapons and the vast majority of
countries in the world are saying we
believe that these weapons have no place
in the world we won't pursue them we
want you to give them up and there's a
strong normative element to that that I
think if you just look at the real
politique and just look at the
international law um you're missing part
of the story if you were in 1945 and you
were you were looking over the future uh
how successful would you say that that
containment of nuclear weapons became in
our world compared to how it how it
could have went I would be horrified at
what happened in the
1960s and the fact that today we still
have thousands of nuclear weapons many
of them on high alert and that we're
preparing to use those weapons we're
rehearsing using them and if something
goes wrong those consequences will be
worse than what happened in World War II
and it'll be that'll be just day one
right that's horrifying you know some of
the observers in 1945 feared that future
and tried to stop that future so I
talked about Robert Oppenheimer but it
applies to many of the the scientists
and even military leaders who were
confronted with this new weapon that's
the future they wanted to avoid and
unfortunately I think we still have that
reality with us now on the other hand I
would be pleas ly surprised that these
weapons had not been used again after
1945 that's kind of surprising we've had
these weapons we spent a lot of money on
them we've threatened to use them under
many circumstances and yet there has not
been another detonation in war since
1945 so that's a pretty good track
record and I think in part that track
record of success has led to some
complacency among people to think that
because these weapons haven't been used
that they can never be used
and that there's something intrinsic
about these weapons and about nuclear
deterrence that makes it more or less
foolproof and I don't think that's the
case I would be surprised in 1945 that
these weapons had only spread to nine
countries I'd also be surprised about
what those nine countries are what are
those nine countries actually so you
have the US Russia China UK and
France as well as India Pakistan
Israel North Korea and then you have
what many argue is a nuclear weapons
program in Iran that is cloaked in a
civilian nuclear power program but you
know th those are the nine countries
that have them so far and there aren't a
lot of countries on the horizon that
seem poised to get nuclear weapons um
with the possible exception of Iran some
of those are are are definitely
surprising from the perspective of 1945
so the main impediment right now to more
countries getting nuclear weapons it's
not the international legal regime it's
not the sanctions regime the main reason
more countries don't have nuclear
weapons is because they've chosen not to
get nuclear weapons and politically in
most of these countries it would be very
difficult to reverse their stance on
nuclear weapons and to decide they
wanted to build a nuclear Arsenal I say
difficult it's certainly not impossible
and especially if we have nuclear use if
we have nuclear war there's going to be
a re-evaluation in a number of countries
that have been anti-nuclear as to
whether or not they need to acquire
these weapons to ensure their security I
also think that if the US were to step
back from some of its formal and
informal treaty commitments you'd see an
interest at least in exploring nuclear
weapons by some of these countries
so we've talked about how containment
has been relatively successful U what
about deescalation how did the world
manage to go from I don't know you can
give me the exact number of Warheads at
the top of the Cold War to to a a highly
reduced number today how did disarmament
happen in the 1980s there were about
60,000 nuclear warheads in the world and
today we have between 10 and 12,000
nuclear weapons depending on how you
measure them it's an interesting story
about how we cut four fifths of our
arsenals and most people didn't really
notice a lot of it was at the end of the
Cold War the United States decided to
remove from service a lot of its
tactical nuclear weapons it was a
decision by George HW Bush to remove
nuclear weapons from the surface ships
and the tactical nuclear weapons and it
was reciprocated by Russia and Boris
yelson and so you have had a really
rapid decrease in the number of weapons
and subsequently they negotiated some
Arms Control treaties which limited the
number of deployed weapons and a lot of
weapons were then marked Surplus or
slated for dismantlement and since 90%
of the nuclear weapons were in the hands
of the United States and Russia it was
relatively straightforward to cut that
number really significantly these
countries were also in the midst of
modernizing and they had more accurate
missiles and better Conventional Weapons
which allowed them to rely Less on large
nuclear warheads to deter the other side
there's also a hope in the postc Cold
War period that us and Russia could well
maybe if not being friends at least they
could uh work together on a variety of
global issues and some extent they did
but in recent years things have gotten
really really bad um so I think we could
would start to see that number ticking
up again you know during this period
starting in the 1990s even as you have
the global stockpile of nuclear weapons
decreasing you have an increase in the
arsenals among some smaller States so
particularly India and Pakistan start to
build up their nuclear arsenals North
Korea builds up its nuclear Arsenal
China is the interesting story because
for a long time they've had a very small
recessed nuclear deterrent so they have
a no first use nuclear policy which says
they they won't use nuclear weapons
unless nuclear weapons are used against
them they traditionally have not had
their Warheads mated to their missiles
so they something of a recess deterrent
and they've relied on a relatively small
number their view is that no country
would be willing to suffer even a
handful of nuclear attacks and that they
don't need to have a large diverse
nuclear arsenal of the type that the
Soviet Union and the United States
developed during the Cold War and I
believe that that view is starting to
change in China I think it's already
changed they basically want an Arsenal
that is on par with what the US and
Russia have today and they're spending a
lot of money and a lot of effort to get
there over the next decade what explains
this why did they change their strategy
I think a major factor there is they
started to question whether their
nuclear Arsenal was
sufficient and they started to question
that because they saw the rapid
Improvement in US capabilities
especially in US conventional
capabilities to be able to strike
targets from long distances with high
precision and concern over US missile
defenses in 2002 George Bush pulls the
United States out of the anti-ballistic
missile treaty and embarks on a
reinvigorated missile defense strategy
um the argument for doing this is to
protect the United States from small
countries like North Korea or
potentially Iran or Iraq but from
China's perspective their view is that
the US is seeking nuclear Primacy and
seeking to be able to coer and Bully
them during a crisis and even though the
missile defenses they're not a lot of
interceptors and they're not very good
Chinese military plannner start to worry
about what will come next us is spending
a lot of money on this why would they be
spending so much money unless they had
designs at ultimately negating our
Arsenal and so China starts to to invest
in their capabilities I think another
factor is just that they had more money
available they have a larger economy
their upgr grading all aspects of their
military and so it was peculiar that
they had Exempted nuclear weapons from
that modernization program so they
decide we're not going to exempt it
anymore we're going to start spending a
lot of money on our nuclear weapons and
we're going to start developing the type
of file material that allows us to have
uh a lot more weapons the picture that
you're painting for us here is is as I
see it of two successes containment of
nuclear weapons and disarm arment from
the height of the Cold War to now and
then a a beginning failure of
international coroporation and diplomacy
and the treaties we rely on and so on an
overarching question here is which
coordination mechanisms can countries
used to successfully decrease nuclear
risk well there are a few different
coordination mechanisms one of them is
formal treaties in which you agree not
to exceed a certain number of warheads
and you provide some verific a
mechanisms in place to ensure that both
sides are agreeing or all sides are
agreeing right now I don't see any
Prospect for continuing this treaty
based approach in the short term the uh
apprehension and mistrust between United
States Russia and China is too high so
instead you're left to rely on a less
formal mechanism which is essentially
signaling how can we signal our
intentions without verifiable treaties
in place and I think the US would be
wise to adopt approach to say that we
are going to hedge against Bad possible
future scenarios without catalyzing them
by taking actions that will lead to uh a
response so again I think it comes back
to understanding how many nuclear
weapons are
enough and not building more I think
that the current number of nuclear
weapons in the US it's 1550 deployed
nuclear
weapons across a variety of platforms
I'm hardpressed to think of scenarios in
which that is not enough and so you need
to resist the political pressures to say
hey because the other guy is building
more weapons we need to build them too
that requires a certain amount of cover
courage and in some cases it might be a
loser on the domestic political stage so
it's important that we create space for
politicians to adopt a policy of nuclear
sufficiency instead of seeking some form
of nuclear Primacy which while it's
tempting to do that while it's tempting
to have an advantage and to seem
stronger history suggests that that
Advantage will be short-lived because an
adversary that has enough money will
find ways to respond to build more
weapons to build
countermeasures and then both sides will
end up worse off than they are before
your thinking on treaties and their
perhaps Bleak prospects is that feeling
shared by your colleagues in the field
yeah I think those who are honest with
themselves would you know to give you
one example of obstacles to Future
treaties even if you were to have one
negotiated you would need two-thirds of
the Senate to ratify that treaty you
can't get two-thirds of the Senate to
age that it's Monday there's just so
much distrust in the US political system
I I could be wrong maybe under a
Republican president who negotiates a
treaty and then sells it to the
Republican party as an important
contribution uh you might be able to
have that treaties in general have a lot
of benefits and one of those is they
offer you
predictability so the Pentagon can plan
ahead based on a particular set of
requirements because we know that at
least until
2026 Russia will be kept at 1550
strategic deployed Warheads right after
2026 all bets are off and that
unpredictability can cause a lot of
problems for everyone involved can we
actually rely on Russia staying under a
certain number of nuclear weapons until
the treaties run out it seems like a
strange situation if it's common
knowledge that they will break the the
number defined in the treat after 2026
why aren't they just doing it now then
so last year Russia announced that it
was suspending its participation in the
new start treaty there's nothing in the
treaty that permits a suspension of this
sort they have said that it's because of
us actions in Ukraine and so there is no
longer the types of onsite inspections
and information Exchange changes that
could guarantee more or less that
they're at a certain level is there
likely to be a meaningful increase
beyond that number well we know that
Russia could upload some missiles to
their existing system so they could
cheat on this agreement but it's
unlikely to be militarily or
strategically significant so most people
I've talked to believe that Russia will
remain in compliance more or less with
the treaty until it expires you know
it's going to happen soon and there are
no real benefits to to exceeding the
limits before then could technology come
to the rescue here is there any
interesting technology on the horizon
that would make it easier for us to
cooperate as a world uh in in reducing
nuclear risk well I think technology has
played a key role in improving
transparency and verification and you
think about the tools that the
International atomic energy agency has
now at its disposal and the tools that
it could have as at its disposal given
the prevalence of ubiquitous Sensi in
other fields you could play a thought
experiment and imagine that nuclear
weapons only arrived on the scene in
2023 rather than in
1945 it would be possible to have the
type of uh intrusive verification regime
it was envisioned uh in the baroo plan
and maybe have that actually succeed
given the Technologies we have available
to us now but obviously at the time they
had a lot less insight into what was
going on into other countries so
verification technology will be really
important in managing nuclear risks
going forward as it pertains both to
nonproliferation and to Arms Control and
disarmament treaties if we're ever able
to negotiate another treaty we will need
to have significant innovation in terms
of what we can measure and how at a
recent conference I spoke with rose
Giller and she's the former negotiator
of the new start treaty and she
describes how once you get to a certain
point you need to start moving from
Counting Delivery Systems which is what
the current treaties do to actually
counting warheads and that's a much
harder problem and it's a problem to
which we can develop technological
solutions but there hasn't been enough
attention to that particular problem you
need to be able to verify that something
is a warhead without revealing any
sensitive design information or
complicating military operations too
much that's a thorny technical challenge
but there's lots of really great tools
in the world of cryptography and um
observation that that might be able to
help with this you're thinking zero
knowledge proofs specifically which is
an an an interesting and recently
invented field or at least a recently
invented subfield of of cryptography
yeah that many many applications not
only nuclear but in in in many aspects
of human cooperation so there's another
way in which technology is going to
affect nuclear operations in the coming
years and that is as War moves faster
and is increasingly fought at machine
speed we will be integrating artificial
intelligence into our nuclear command
and control processes as a way to
support decision makers and there are
some countries that will find this
controversial but ultimately a lot of AI
is essentially software and it helps
people operate complicated systems in a
timely way so we are likely to see AI
integrated in a variety of nuclear
support missions it might make the world
safer until it doesn't um that's one of
the problems is uh turning over some of
these decis decisions essentially to an
algorithm and you can imagine if War
moves so quickly that humans are not
able to process the information
independently they'll be relying on the
the inputs from digital systems to to
guide them and that's kind of a scary
world actually future of Life Institute
you did a video on this right we did
yeah H we picture a scenario where AI
enables the US and China to act much
faster but they also lose control of the
process in a way that turns out to be
destructive to the world yeah so that I
found that scenario pretty scary and I
think folks should go out and watch that
video it's really well done there are
other scenarios too you could imagine
you could imagine some countries using
an AI to allow them to essentially
develop a dead hand system that
guarantees retaliation in a crisis and
this of course Echoes the Doomsday
Machine from Doctor Strange Love right
there may be some incentives for
countries to do that and that's really
scary so we need to stay on top of this
and the time to start working on this
and to start to limit the use of these
systems and nuclear operations is now
because once the system is developed and
deployed it's really hard to take it
offline I'm concerned about this trend I
don't think it changes the laws of
nature with regard to nuclear weapons
but it's something we need to stay on
top of do think we can retain the human
in the loop as a as a legal mechanism or
or will that eventually become a
formality I mean there there are efforts
now in the US Congress to mandate that
and to ensure it I don't know what it
means to have a human in the loop a
human can be required to make a decision
but what if they're making that decision
based on information that's mediated
through a variety of digital systems
it's a hard challenge and for me at the
heart it's not a technological problem
it is a problem that is driven by the
Need for Speed in nuclear operations so
we have this vision
of responding in a really prompt way to
a nuclear
crisis and that's going to compress the
decision time whether it's a human
making the decision or an algorithm and
fundamentally that's the problem we need
to move away from
procedures that require us to launch the
missiles within 15
minutes and allow for sanity to Prevail
that makes a lot of sense to me okay
what about the the interaction of of
nuclear warfare with other types of War
Warfare so for example today's nuclear
facilities in different countries how
vulnerable are these facilities to cyber
warfare or to Conventional Warfare so
this is an underappreciated
transformation in nuclear strategy over
the past 30 years or so uh during the
Cold War there was an assumption and I
think it was largely correct that
nuclear weapons could only be targeted
by other nuclear weapons right so this
would allow you to develop systems in
which both sides are reducing their
nuclear warheads and when they reduce
their number of warheads deployed they
also are reducing the number of targets
that the other side has to Target and so
you can have this um beneficial
reduction as conventional missiles
became more and more accurate all of the
sudden you had the potential for
Conventional Weapons to destroy nuclear
platforms to be able to hit missiles um
you know you've always had this be the
case with submarines for example where
an attack submarine could destroy a
ballistic missile submarine and take out
with it lots and lots of nuclear
warheads but now groundbased missiles
also started to become vulnerable or
potentially vulnerable and people debate
the extent to which this is true but
that that's something of a change how we
think about nuclear weapons and cyber
creates another Avenue for disruption So
within the parament of missile defense
there uh are approaches called Left of
launch which involved trying to take out
the adversaries missiles before they
could ever be launched either through
cyber means or other means right
countries are really concerned about
this and have sought to strengthen the
reliability of their nuclear command and
control but it's really a cat and mouse
game and nobody knows how safe all of
these arsenals are and fortunately we
haven't had a nuclear crisis in which
that's been tested but as a response to
this kind of
vulnerability countries are taking and
we can imagine them taking more steps in
the future to insulate themselves
against being preempted and so in the
case of China they're investing very
heavily in getting a more Diversified
nuclear Arsenal and trying to find ways
to to hide missiles and build them at
missile sites deep in the interior of
China where they can't be easily reached
and you know North Korea has
dramatically upgraded its nuclear
infrastructure same with India and
Pakistan Etc so um I think that this
fear of vulnerability is driving this
new wave of nuclear improvements which
I've called a nuclear arms race um and I
think it's it could well accelerate how
do you think about the public perception
of nuclear risk is the public
potentially bored of of nuclear risk
it's been hanging over our heads for
something like 80 years and naively you
might think no nothing has happened and
so this this threat is is maybe not as
potent as as it seemed do you think the
public is is bored about hearing about
about nuclear risk I think that some
people have kind of checked out this is
a risk that's in the background I can't
do anything about it so why should I
worry about it um and have moved on to
other issues um many of which have a
much stronger emotive element to them
which they feel a little bit more
personal agency or threats that seem
novel and kind of spicy compared to this
you know that's really you know nuclear
weapons isn't that my parents problem
isn't that my grandparents problem like
why should I be and I you know I also
get it like we all have so many things
to worry about do we really need another
thing to worry about um I think it's
important that we consider these risks
that we're taking and the risks that are
being taken in our name in order to
provide security because absent some
level of public oversight we're likely
to have this out outof control threat
inflation and policies that are really
driven by military bureaucracy IES
rather than by the public interest and
certainly those military bureaucracies
have a lot of insights into the problem
and there are a lot of good people
working on these problems in government
but there's also a need for a a public
voice on this issue as you say I think a
lot of people have kind of checked out
I'm hoping that this recent crisis in
Ukraine will remind people that nuclear
weapons are here and that we need to
work every generation needs to work as
part of its project to ensure that these
weapons don't extinguish us because
nuclear weapons have only been with us
for 80 years and the knowledge of how to
create nuclear
detonations is likely to remain with
Humanity as long as we're here we're
going to have to learn to manage it or
we're going to go off the rails at some
point yeah this could quickly go from
boring to deeply horrific apocalyptic
even I mean boring is good I want a
world in which my children never have to
think about nuclear weapons and which
they say that was my father's problem
right that's the world I want to work
towards yeah that would be beautiful do
you think it's likely that we will see a
10th nuclear uh Nation or nuclear
country I mean at some point in human
history I would I would think so within
this Century let's say I think the the
country that's knocking on the door
right now is Iran you know we had a
nuclear deal The Joint comprehensive
plan of action with Iran it was a good
deal that limited their activities with
a lot of verification into what they
were doing it was incomplete and it
wasn't perfect and no deal will be
perfect but that deal is long gone and
there's so much distrust between both
sides between all sides it's going to be
really hard to manage this and I think
Iran every month slips a little closer
to acquiring a nuclear weapon and now
you've seen Saudi Arabia which has come
to the US and said we want to start
having access to nuclear enrichment um
so that if Iran ever gets a nuclear
weapon you know we we'll have an option
you could imagine a new Cascade of
proliferation I don't know how likely it
is it really depends on what happens
next are nuclear weapons becoming easier
to develop such that perhaps a terrorist
group at some point could develop them
on their own so nuclear weapons have
become both easier and harder to develop
they've become harder to develop because
we have much better controls on weapons
usable fistle material and much better
controls on the nuclear fuel cycle
through the international atomic energy
agency there is a ro more robust system
of international surveillance and
awareness of anything that's going on
anywhere in the planet we all leave
digital signatures but there are also
satellites overhead so I think it's
harder to operate in secrecy than it
ever was
before but as I said from the start this
is an 80-year-old technology it requires
solving some difficult engineering
problems but it's not unobtainable and I
think as technology advances
each year it empowers us to do more with
less right so you think about you know
just just software allows us to produce
and edit documents better and faster
than we were ever able to do before and
Manufacturing has gotten it's much
gotten much easier to move from a
concept to a finished product
Transformers are the next phase in this
right and so we have powerful artificial
intelligence systems which allow any
individual in the world to harness a lot
of knowledge and reasoning that's
available for example a non-state actor
operating today to build nuclear weapons
still needs to master all of the various
disciplines and processes that would
give them a nuclear bomb but their
cognitive capabilities and their
knowledge is now enhanced by access to
these really powerful tools
so I think it is getting easier to build
nuclear weapons the fundamental
bottleneck is acquiring the weapons
usable fistle material which is either
enriched uranium or plutonium it's hard
to get but as especially if we have a
world with more nuclear
power which is a world that I'm
optimistic to see I would like to see us
getting more electricity from nuclear
energy relative to where we are today
but if that is not managed carefully if
there are a lot more nuclear enrichment
and reprocessing Facilities if there's a
lot more nuclear power plants everywhere
in the world it will allow for greater
access I think right now if you were to
tell me tomorrow that a non-state actor
had gotten access to a nuclear weapon I
would say well who gave it to them
that's the the easiest pathway right now
in 20 years we might be in a world in
which it's easier to manufacture
anything the barriers to a nuclear
weapon might be very small and I think
Nick Bostrom has this thought experiment
in which he imagines a vulnerable World
in which you could take some sand and
put it in the microwave and have a a
nuclear detonation we're not there and I
don't think we'll ever get there I think
it's probably easier to destroy the
world using other Technologies
unfortunately but I do think the the
barriers to acquiring nuclear weapons
probably do decrease um a little bit
every year and that's why it's important
to be vigilant and to have these
mechanisms of control also improve every
year how do you imagine us reaching a a
truly stable state in the in the future
where we have reduced nuclear risks such
that it's not something we have to worry
about I think
fundamentally stability in the nuclear
space requires finding conflict
resolution means between countries that
have nuclear weapons or might want
nuclear weapons right it's less about
the technology itself and it's more
about the way we resolve our differences
as long as there have been humans on the
planet there has been competitions
between groups of humans and sometimes
they could be quite brutal but we live
in a world now where the means of
Destruction at our disposal are so much
greater than they've ever been that we
need to figure out how to resolve our
differences and fast because nuclear
weapons along with
biotechnology and AI these pose a shared
problem that confronts everyone on this
planet and we need to think of them not
just as tools and assets and something
we can use to gain an advantage but as
something that we need to manage
collectively as a shared problem in the
1980s you see a change that happens and
Reagan and gorbachov come together and
actually start discussing nuclear
weapons as this shared problem it's a
paradigm shift it comes in 1983 after
one of the worst scares of the Cold War
in which the US learns that the Soviet
Union believed that the US Was preparing
for preemptive nuclear war against the
Soviet Union yeah there was this Abel
Archer exercise in November
1983 it was a regularly scheduled NATO
military exercise but it also had a
nuclear component in which the leaders
of NATO were preparing a decision around
nuclear weapons so this was from the US
perspective an ordinary exercise but
tensions were really high with the
Soviet Union at this moment you had the
the Reagan arms buildup you had the
Strategic Defense Initiative there had
been recently the the shootdown of a
Korean civilian jet um a lot of
civilians died including a US
Representative so there's this high
tension and at that time NATO has this
military exercise that involved
preparing and executing a nuclear war
and the Soviet Union takes this very
seriously we know now from their
archival material that they had this
project Ryan which was monitoring things
like the number of cars in Pentagon
parking lots and the amount of blood in
uh hospitals like uh blood banks across
the us as a way of as indicators that
the US might be prepared to go to war
around this time too you have the
stanislav Petrov incident and which the
light glinting off clouds is confused
for five incoming nuclear missiles and
Petro who is a lieutenant colonel he's
the launch officer who's on duty that
day uh sees this and his job is to
report that to his superiors um and
presumably there would been an
initiation of a a launch sequence that
would follow um and he decides he's not
going to report that he thinks this this
pattern doesn't make any sense to me why
would the US launch an attack with only
five warheads and he knows that there's
some technical limitations to the system
so he sits on the information and you
know it's later revealed to be a false
alarm this is just one of the incidents
and um moments of anxiety during this
period right and later on Ronald Reagan
learns how scared the Soviet Union was
that the US would use nuclear weapons
and he says that's crazy why would they
think we would do
that and so he feels like it's incumbent
upon himself and he communicates this to
to Gorbachev who's come in with a
platform of uh glass noos and perista
and the two men really see eye to eye on
this issue and they're not able to
achieve the ambitious goals they set for
themselves but they are at least able to
come away from that meeting feeling that
neither side is about to initiate a
nuclear war uh and that becomes this
this foundation for further risk
reduction that is the kind of
collaboration we must get to again in
order to have a better chance of
surviving yeah they started telling a
different story about what these weapons
are and really looked at them as this as
this shared problem and we need to
return to that framework it's really
hard to do right now uh you know while
Russia is occupying Ukraine and with all
of the belligerent rhetoric on both
sides between the US and China and
between India and Pakistan but we need
to recapture that spirit makes sense to
me call thank you for coming on the
podcast it's been a real pleasure oh
thank you I really enjoyed our
conversation